we are the only memory in all the
Himalayas in deadly martial art these
nuns can even break bricks with her
hands and the purpose behind this
practice is sacred
this is it like long box I make it for
to Basel and I am very proud of my
practice my name is jing-mei
eunjin comma Sigma means fearless I am a
component of the Troopa order the Drupa
order is a branch of Buddhism that has
been around for thousands of years but
in 2008 the nunnery based in Katmandu
Nepal started to learn kung fu as part
of their spiritual practice a generated
nuns I here to eat reporter Nam jig may
wanted to be a nun since she was a
little girl I'm ten years old when I
became a man I can say all the nuns
right my family no other nunnery in
Nepal does come through training and
Jigme and her sisters go the extra mile
to master this art form the true power
is not for lazy people we wake up at 3
a.m. we meditate we bicycle we train for
3 hours they run and climb up stairs to
strengthen their bodies and they use
sticks and fans to enhance their
coordination the hard work is rewarding
and the purpose of training these nuns
to fight all comes back to the
philosophies of peace and equality over
trained us to focus outline for
meditation
the nuns also take these philosophies
and apply them to disadvantaged
communities in Nepal
in 2015 when a devastating earthquake
hit Kathmandu the nuns knew this was
their call to action bring the Aquacade
Hong Kong Virginia help us to brave and
strong we went to many villages that
many NGOs and government thought that
it's too dangerous
we brought many supplies we survived the
landslide avalanches and out quick
the nuns also biked 14,000 miles
throughout Nepal to protest against the
human trafficking of women and girls we
talk a lot equality and safety
we wanted to show everyone that lawns
can ride bicycle and the girls can do
anything I learned I can do anything
from banking compo has trained me to be
confident strong and happy the teachings
helped me put my compassion into action
helping others is my religion
[Music]